Both the brain and law regulate human behavior.
Only recently have all of these lit medical
tools became available:
CTs, MEG, ERPs, and my favorite, the fMRI,
which allows the human brain itself to finally
be studied.
We now have a dope set of brain-imaging techniques,
so can we use our fantastic new neural knowledge
in the courtroom? Can we?
Well, the intersection of neuroscience and
law is called neurolaw.
You can deadass put neuro in front of anything
and make it cooler! Watch.
Neurocountry music… nevermind, I broke it
already.
In fact, “my brain made me do it” is becoming
a more popular defense in the courts — such
as blaming earlier head trauma or brain disorders
for criminal actions.
On one hand, a person in court using the excuse
that “my brain did the crime” is in the
wrong; any neurotypical person should act
in a prosocial way, obey the law, and only
use their brain to, I don't know, tweet memes.
On the other hand, that person in court is
in the right; the brain did make them do something
and if neurological evidence shows that they
have abnormal activity in their brain or a
previously undiagnosed disorder, these things
should be taken into consideration.
And there are different legal terms to define
a defendant’s culpability, or even an individual’s
capacity to take the stand.
These defenses argue competency, criminal
responsibility, and diminished capacity of
the defendant, causing them to commit the
crime in question.
However, these are based on psychological
evaluations — which are 100% cut and dry
in the courtroom.
Right?
Well, you're wrong.
For example, memories of events are very important
in courtrooms but memories are not fully reliable.
They deteriorate over time, trauma might make
us remember events very differently from our
points of view, people are really good at
remembering the gist of things but details
are more difficult, and the way questions
about those details are asked could make people
remember details falsely.
And that’s why we use lie detectors, right?
Nope.
If you’ve watched any courtroom procedural
you’ve probably heard that lie detector
tests are “inadmissible in court.”
Why?
Well, a polygraph measures blood pressure,
perspiration, and heart rate and attempts
to correlate them with telling lies.
Those metrics aren’t 100% correlational
which makes them unreliable.
But what’s stronger than a lie detector?
An fMRI, perhaps?
First, yes, fMRIs have been found to be able
to differentiate truth vs lies by changes
in prefrontal cortex activity, but a guilty
suspect who firmly believes that they are
not guilty may be able to finesse a false
positive in a fMRI study.
Furthermore, even if fMRIs find an increase
in activity in certain regions of the brain
when a subject is lying, this does not mean
that that increase in activity means that
the participant has to be lying.
Again, correlation, not causation.
So what is neurolaw good for...absolutely
nothing??
... Moment of Truth…Rush Hour? Edwin Starr? Good God, y'all.
Until concrete, infallible techniques can
be brought to the stand, neurolaw’s at a
standstill.
Both medical and legal procedures need to
be taken into account to bring neuroscience
into the courtroom.
Both a bar council and a medical board would
need to come together regularly to review
the techniques and advances in order to bridge
the two disciplines.
More knowledge about the use of science in
law and law in neuroscience would need to
be added to curricula so future neurolawyers
can grasp how their disciplines would be used.
(“Neurolawyer” is such a dope job.
Immediate right swipe.)
Now, I may be a simple city science boy, but
in my humble opinion, neurolaw would help
us apply medical knowledge and technology
to the law as it stands to make a more equitable
legal system.
Mental health status, racial bias, and deterioration
or damage of decision making or impulse control
areas of the brain could help prove liability
could do wonders in the courtroom.
Yo thanks for watching.
Make sure you subscribe to Seeker.
Speaking of crimes and brains, guess what,
we’ve got more crime and brains for you.
Check out this other episode about how Einstein’s
brain was stolen, preserved, dissected, and
sent across the whole country in pieces.
That’s crazy.
And if you’re really in your feelings, good
or bad, leave me a comment below.
And again thank you so much for watching.